What is your experience?
I think for me being in the world, tech means constantly learning.
There's always new technologies coming out, new programming languages,
and to be in tech means to constantly learn those new things,
but also have fun while doing that.
Being in the world of tech, I think there's so many different fields that you can go into within tech.
There's software, hardware, machine learning, computer vision.
Even within the same company you can try out different languages.
You can constantly evolve and technology is always developing,
so there's constantly new things to be picking up and learning.
Since you guys have recently started university, what does being in the tech means be?
I think for me, yeah, I only just started at university,
and it's immediately both so exciting but also really daunting that, like you said,
there's just so much, and there's so much information and so much to learn,
and so much still being developed that I could get involved in, that I could learn about.
But I'm just excited to start really.
Just wanna be me!